FUNNY LINE, BINGE WATCHING A
MARRIOTT HOTEL COMMERCIAL.
THAT’S PRETTY FUNNY.
THIS IS BEYOND A REALLY, REALLY
BAD INFOMERCIAL.
OKAY, IT WAS BORING, IT WAS
AWKWARD, IT WAS DISJOINTED.
WHAT’S WORSE IS, ZERO SUBSTANCE,
NOTHING.
WE HEARD NO REAL SOLUTIONS ON
HOW THEY WILL IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NO POLICY DISCUSSIONS, NO
MENTION OF THE CRISIS IN
AMERICAN DISASTROUS DEMOCRATIC
RUN CITIES, NO NEW PROPOSALS TO
COMBAT B.A.-19.
THEY WERE MISSING IN ACTION,
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS XENOPHOBIC
AND HYSTERICAL TO PUT THE TRAVEL
BAN IN EFFECT, THEY WERE
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT, IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR TRIAL, NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND, NO MENTIONS OF HOW
TO MAKE THIS COUNTRY MORE SAFE,
MORE SECURE, WEALTHIER,
PROSPEROUS, NONE OF THAT.
WHAT YOU GOT WAS A TEMPER
TANTRUM, BUMPER STICKER SLOGANS
ABOUT PRETTY MUCH HOW MUCH THEY
HATE DONALD TRUMP AND HATRED OF
HIM IS HATRED OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S, IRREDEEMABLE
DEPLORABLE SCUM OF THE 15%,
BIDEN SAYS.
THE ANGRY PEOPLE OBAMA TALKED
ABOUT THAT CLING TO GOD, GUILTY.
OUR SECOND AMENDMENT, GUILTY.
BIBLES, GUILTY.
AND RELIGION, BELIEF IN GOD,
GUILTY AGAIN.
I LIKE TO SAVE MONEY AT WALMART.
MY BOOK IS REALLY PRICED LOW
THERE, LIKE COSTCO.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BURY THE,
ANDREW CUOMO BLAMING TRUMP FOR A
WHAT HE IS CALLING THE EUROPEAN
CORONAVIRUS.
NEVER MIND THE THOUSANDS OF
SENIORS WHO DIED BECAUSE OF HIS
DISASTROUS NURSING HOME POLICY.
A NEW REPORT OUT TODAY AS A
MATTER OF FACT, ANDREW.
THE TRUE NURSING HOME DEATHS,
CLOAKED IN SECRECY, THEY SAID.
COULDN’T BE MORE THAN 11,000
PEOPLE.
NOT THE 6,000 THEY ARE SAYING.
THEN OF COURSE, WOLF AND
PENNSYLVANIA, MURPHY IN
NEW JERSEY, WE HAD OUR OLD PAL
OHIO GOVERNOR JOHN KASICH,
REALLY BAD CASE OF SORE LOSER
LOSERRITIS.
KIND OF LIKE THE RECENTLY
DECEASED JOHN McCAIN, HE WAS
ANGRY ABOUT LOSING AS IS
HILLARY CLINTON, AL GORE, AND
MITT ROMNEY.
HE DELIVERED, JOHN KASICH, HIS
OWN BITTER, ANTI-TRUMP RANCH.
PRETTY MUCH RECANTED EVERYTHING
HE SAID HE PUBLICLY BELIEVED IN.
AND THEN THE FORMER FIRST LADY
MICHELLE OBAMA PRAISED BY
EVERYBODY IN THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA AND DURING WHAT WERE
PRETTY VINDICTIVE AND INACCURATE
AND UNTRUE REMARKS, SHE WAS SO
BUSY TRASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP,
SHE DIDN’T EVEN MENTION KAMALA
HARRIS, THE FIRST FEMALE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ON A
PRESIDENTIAL TICKET ALTHOUGH
ACCORDING TO REPORTS,
MICHELLE OBAMA APPARENTLY
PRETAPED TO THE SPEECH PRIOR TO
BIDEN’S VP ANNOUNCEMENT AND
COULD IT BE BOTHERED TO RE-TAPE
IT.
HAD ALMOST A FULL WEEK TO TAPE
FOR THE RECORD, OBAMA DISPARAGED
REPUBLICANS ALL THE TIME, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY
DIVISIVE.
BY THE WAY, HIS RECORD ON THE
ECONOMY, 13 MORE 13 MORE A MILLI
AMERICANS FOOD STAMPS, WAS
RECOVERY SINCE HE ’40s, I CAN
GO ON.
FOREIGN POLICY, REALLY?
BOTH DISASTERS.
THE ONLY PERSON WHO ACTUALLY
GAVE ANY SUBSTANCE AT ALL, GOT
TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE IT’S DUE,
HERE HE IS, CONRAD
BERNIE SANDERS, BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE.
HE USED TO BE AN ANNOYANCE ON
THE FRINGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AN OUTLIER,
BARELY EVEN TOLERATED.
EVERYONE THERE BACK THEN, MANY
DEMOCRATS EMBARRASSED BY SANDERS
RADICAL SOCIALIST AGENDA.
NOW HE IS THE SIGNAL CALLER,
LEADER IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE CONTROLS THE PARTY’S AGENDA,
HELPED COAUTHOR BIDEN’S ECONOMIC
PLATFORM.
IN OTHER WORDS, BIDEN
PLAGIARIZED BIG PORTIONS OF IT.
HE IS NOW THE MAINSTREAM OF WHAT
IS NOW THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
THIS IS THE MOST EXTREME TICKET
OF ANY MAJOR PARTY IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
DON’T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT, LET’S
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT
BERNIE SANDERS HAD TO SAY LAST
NIGHT.
HE’S THE LEADER, THE ECONOMIC
STAR FOR JOE AND KAMALA, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> OUR CAMPAIGN ENDED SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO, BUT OUR MOVEMENT
CONTINUES AND IS GETTING
STRONGER EVERY DAY.
MANY OF THE IDEAS WE FOUGHT FOR
THAT JUST A FEW YEARS AGO WERE
CONSIDERED RADICAL ARE NOW
MAINSTREAM.
>> Sean: THAT’S ACTUALLY TRUE.
NO OIL, NO GAS, EVERYTHING IS
FREE, FREE, FREAK.
UNLESS YOU PAY TAXES.
IF YOU ARE A TAXPAYER, WITH ANY
WEALTH AT ALL, BUCKLE UP.
THEY WILL CONFISCATE YOUR
WEALTH, RAISE TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TAXES WITH THE FALSE
PROMISES THAT WILL NEVER BE
FULFILLED, SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
BY THE WAY, YOU CAN KISS THE
SENATE FILIBUSTER GOOD-BYE.
THEY WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
RAM THIS RADICAL WISH LIST RIGHT
THROUGH CONGRESS AND THERE IS
THE TROJAN HORSE AS THE
PRESIDENT IS REFERRING TO
JOE BIDEN, HE WILL SIGN
ANYTHING.
DANGEROUS AGENDA, DANGEROUS
POSSIBILITIES BUT HEY,
BERNIE SANDERS, GOT TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT.
HE HAD ENERGY, STRENGTH,
STAMINA, MENTAL ALERTNESS,
MENTAL ACUITY TO COHERENTLY,
ENERGETICALLY GIVE THE MOST
PASSIONATE SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
NOW BERNIE IS A YEAR OLDER THAN
JOE BIDEN’S OF THE CRITICISM
ABOUT BIDEN’S STRUGGLES LIKE
THERE WAS CRITICISM ABOUT REAGAN
AND JOHN McCAIN IS NOT ABOUT
AGE.
INSTEAD IT’S WHAT WE SEE EVERY
SINGLE TIME JOE BIDEN PRETTY
MUCH OPENS HIS MOUTH WHEN HE
DARES TO VENTURE OUT OF THE
BASEMENT BUNKER.
TODAY HE ACTUALLY GOT HIS
DECADES MIXED UP AND YEARS MIXED
UP.
YET AGAIN.
WATCH.
>> AND 40 YEARS LATER TO THE
MONTH, IN JANUARY OF 2018, I
FOUND MYSELF IN A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE, ACTUALLY, 2012.
I FOUND MYSELF STANDING IN THE
SAME SPOT I HAD STOOD FOUR YEARS
EARLIER AND I WAS WAITING FOR A
BLACK MAN, TOM, TO COME PICK ME
UP FROM PHILADELPHIA.
A GUY NAMED ROCCO BARACK OBAMA.
A TRIP I MADE THOUSAND TIMES
COMMUTING EVERY DAY, NOT TO BE
SWORN IN AS PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: JOE, YOU WERE
INAUGURATED AS VICE PRESIDENT,
YOU MIGHT WANT TO WRITE IT DOWN
IN YOUR TELEPROMPTER.
THAT WAS 2009, NOT 2018 AND NOT
2012.
GLAD WE GOT THAT OUT OF THE WAY.
NOW, JOE BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN A
GREAT SPEAKER AND NO ONE IS EVER
REALLY BEEN INSPIRED BY A BIDEN
SPEECH.
GO BACK FIVE YEARS AGO, YOU
SHOULD SEE THE ADS THE RNC PUT
OUT.
WE WILL PULL IT UP LATER IN THE
SHOW FOR YOU, JOE THEN AND JOE
NOW PAY A PRETTY ALARMING, SEEMS
FRAIL, HE SEEMS WEAK, HE SEEMS
CONFUSED, OFTEN MIXES UP DAYS OF
THE WEEK, OFTEN MIXES UP EVEN
THE OFFICE HE’S RUNNING FOR.
BUT IT WAS NEVER THIS BAD.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT, DEMOCRATS I KNOW ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT AND EVEN THOSE
FEW PEOPLE I KNOW IN THE MEDIA
MOB, THEY ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT
IT.
THE TROUBLE WITH NUMBERS AND
DATES AND OF COURSE THESE WEIRD
BOUTS WITH ANGER.
ARE YOU AN ADDICT, WHAT’D HE SAY
SAY?
IF YOU HAD A COACH COCAINE TEST,
ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASKED THE
QUESTION THAT EVERYONE IN
AMERICA IS THINKING ABOUT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO JOE BIDEN?
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE.
DOES HE STILL HAVE THE STRENGTH,
THE STAMINA, THE MENTAL
ALERTNESS AND ACUITY HE ONCE
HAD?
YOU DECIDE.
>> I SINCERELY HOPE SOME OF YOU
BECOME MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES.
I MEAN THAT.
BUT ENGAGE IT.
YOU KNOW, THERE’S, DURING
WORLD WAR II, WHERE ROOSEVELT
CAME UP WITH A THING THAT, YOU
KNOW, WAS TOTALLY DIFFERENT THAN
THE, HE CALLED IT, YOU KNOW.
>> Sean: COME ON, MAN, ARE YOU
A JUNKIE?
JOE BIDEN IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
VESSEL FOR THE RADICAL SOCIALIST
LEFT.
THEY KNOW HE CAN BE MANIPULATED
AND WILL BE CONTROLLED.
THAT’S A SCARY, ALL THEY HAVE TO
DO IS GET THEM ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE AND HIDE HIM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
IN JUST 77 SHORT DAYS THIS
COUNTRY WILL EITHER STAY THE
COURSE ON THE PATH OF
PROSPERITY, SECURITY, FREEDOM,
LIBERTY, INVENTION, INNOVATION,
THAT IS MADE THIS THE RICHEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE ADVANCED THE HUMAN
CONDITION BECAUSE OF LIBERTY AND
FREEDOM.
OR WE WILL RISK BECOMING WHAT IS